also getting a report now of a crash off  the freeways and the near southwest  around tropicana and rainbow we'll keep  you posted on that one and we'll hand  the clicker over here to mr elf on the  shelf can you go ahead and say um back  to you john and heather thank you sean  let's move on here at 20 minutes past  five well next on right now we're going  to talk about how much inflation is  costing all of us right now that's right  but something happier the best cities to  celebrate christmas diane king hall  joining us live from new york hi diane  good morning  hi you guys good morning i'm sorry i'm  just cracking up at the elf i just i  can't right now i